your new book I mean as a fellow Texan
there could not be a better title for a
Texan a memoir is called open book yes
and is this like hard that you cuz
normally I would ask people is it hard
to share personal stories but I feel
like we might be similar and it's almost
cathartic it's such a you have no filter
like I have no filter I don't need that
I've never had a future
I think it's just it's very important
just to be yourself and that's what's
also tick and that's what people love
about especially in this boat you open
up about some pretty personal stuff
that's hard to get through and most
people I feel like would be afraid to
say that in the public eye but it's so
brave of you and so cool of you and
strong of you because one when you
address that then you know you're
actually getting past it yeah it
definitely like my openness holds me
accountable and for me like when I
decided to get sober I stopped drinking
and I just had so much clarity that with
my openness it was just like I started
learning so much about myself and why I
had to drink to like try and escape and
like and try and just feel like you know
just normal but that was you know I
thought it was like helping with my
anxiety and I was actually making it
worse yeah cuz people will say they're
like oh it's calming they say that all
the time we find it's all in Italy not
calm I know but I just think it was
really a brave of you to like come out
and and say that and is it has it been
rewarding like getting it has it's been
unbelievable I've been on this book tour
and every city that I'm going into it's
like these people that come up to me so
like I you know I'm gonna be sober like
I'm I want to tell you first before I
tell my family and my parents and it's
connection yeah it's it's a really deep
connection and then I've had mothers
come up to me and I in like thanking me
and like they're not afraid of therapy
like for some reason people afraid we
are so afraid I'm in therapy oh yeah I
love therapy it's like no judgment yeah
you can see whatever you want they're
not in your circle no it'll not be
judged it will not be any but if you are
you don't know I'm you're paying them
yeah exactly
that way they're not your friend my
therapist at the very beginning I was
like oh my gosh I feel like we're best
friends and she goes I wonder I want to
make it very clear that we're not
friends I don't know if anybody's ever
said that to me it's very clear yeah
we're not friends
you know subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going